[Musique]
bienvenue dans pôle it mag spécial
élections municipales les français ont
la parole pendant toute cette campagne
on va tenter de comprendre quelles sont
vos préoccupations au quotidien avec des
reportages sur le terrain
vos remarques et notre sondage sur les
réseaux sociaux et puis bien sûr notre
débat aujourd'hui on va traiter des
déchets la propreté des villes et des
villages de france est une exigence pour
beaucoup de français
et pour en parler nous sommes avec denis
demonpion journaliste et auteur de des
ordures et des hommes aux éditions
buchet chastel
un ouvrage qui a été co écrit d'ailleurs
avec la journaliste mireille dumas face
avoue hervé guillaume coordinateur de
l'association des villes pour la
propreté urbaine également sur ce
plateau frédéric lazorthes essayiste et
chroniqueur au magazine le point
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
sur rt france
nous sommes aussi en direct en direct en
duplex avec patrick mennucci ancien
député ps et conseiller municipal à
marseille les français veulent vivre
dans des villes et des villages propres
ils en font une priorité pour les
élections à venir en particulier dans
des villes comme marseille ou paris deux
métropoles particulièrement mal classés
dans le palmarès européen en matière de
propreté en tout cas avec des métropoles
parfois qualifiée de ville poubelle par
les touristes et par leurs propres
habitants enfin pas tant que ça vous
allez le voir
état des lieux à marseille pour
commencer reportage signé nada jade et
razak et lucas tu as pour hocine
éducateurs dans le monde associatif les
quartiers nord sont particulièrement
délaissées quand on marche en marche
cette pièce est pleine de détritus
c'est plein d'ordures ménagères et puis
et puis avec le vent avec le mistral
ça n'arrête pas de se disputer un peu de
partout on va dans le premier le
deuxième le troisième arrondissement
ça ça toutes les heures où tous les
toutes les 45 minutes ça passe pour
nettoyer il ya les banquiers de la benne
à ordures qui sont là pour nettoyer il
ya tous ceux nécessaires qui est pris en
qui mis en place après vous ferez mesure
que vous décalez vous écarter de
l'épicentre de marseille ça devient
moins mois accessible
on a tendance à la laisser à l'abandon
un petit peu tous ces secteurs-là qui a
qui ne correspond pas assez à cette
personne à ses élus entre guillemets
alors pour tenter d'éradiquer ce fléau
plusieurs pistes sont envisagées
certains souhaitent la création d'une
police de l'environnement d'autres
estiment qu'il faut plus de moyens
augmenter le nombre de poubelles et de
toilettes publiques et mettre en place
des actions de sensibilisation à la
gestion des déchets vous passez dans les
petites rues il ya les poubelles au coin
de la rue vous trouvez des rats morts le
matin il ya des trous voilà c'est la
façade pour les touristes avec des
restaurants super chic et puis les rues
adjacentes elles sont elles sont
dégueulasses marseille historiquement a
toujours été une ville de très sales bon
c'est pas la seule ville de france qui
est concerné par cette problématique
les cv qui ausina civile mais aussi
également tout ce qui est lié au respect
du lieu il suffit de voyager un peu pour
s'apercevoir qu'en france on n'est déjà
pas très propre patte récit
et on n'a pas tendance à chercher une
poubelle pour jeter un papier et
marseille encore moins qu'ailleurs faut
reconnaître aussi que les gens ne sont
pas forcément propres même il faut pas
avoir honte de le dire c'est à dire qu
on voit déjà un peu fumeux j'étais les
paquets qui jette les mecs vous on voit
les gens qui mange un sandwich au bout
de pisa est sur le papier il ya aussi un
manque de
de la part des marseillais de recherche
de propreté quoi ah oui c'est très sale
surtout moi je suis pas marseillaise et
on arrivera ici ça m'a choqué ouais des
poubelles constamment d'un éparpillés
dans la rue ouais assez impressionnant
quand même le vieux port n'est pas
épargné par l'insalubrité en 2010 9 7
tonnes de déchets ont été repêchés des
eaux
une pollution qui a forcément un coût
pour l'environnement
et voilà donc pour le constat à
marseille à denis demonpion vous êtes
auteur de cet ouvrage des ordures et des
hommes j'imagine que vous allez
travailler aussi sur la ville de
marseille
c'est un cas d'école co co auteur avec
mireille darc est d'ailleurs à l'origine
de cette fois je pense que l a fait un
documentaire télé québec c'est lent et
elle m'en a parlé c'est comme ça que
l'idée de faire un livre est venu et en
effet on s'est aperçu à marseille et
qu'il y avait une chose assez
extraordinaire ce qu'ils ont fait un
audit là pour essayer de lutter contre
la présence des rats et on sait que la
présence des rats et les justes liés à
la nourriture que les gens jettent dans
les rues tout simplement
tous les spécialistes vous le diront et
alors ils ont fait un audit qu'ils ont
payé fort cher que draps à marseille il
y en avait beaucoup
mais figurez-vous que comme quand même
un effort a été fait pour éviter que la
nourriture traîne trop dans les rues eh
bien depuis les rats se sont déplacés
sur les plages où les gens vont
abandonnent leur pique nique joue les
reliefs du pique nique et voilà c'est
juste c'est vrai que l'apparition et le
développement des fast food dans les
villes parce que là vous faites un
reportage sur marseille mais c'est
valable dans tente beaucoup de villes
dans toutes les grandes villes toutes
les grandes métropoles et même les
métropole moyenne enfin les villes
moyennes plus exactement c'est la
métropole par définition c'est des
grandes villes eh bien on rencontre ce
même fléau une réaction patrick mennucci
vous qui ne connaissait bien cette ville
de marseille je voulais vous faire un
petit peu la moue contre parler des
reins à marseille c'est le cas ou pas
non mais je crois que les races est un
peu anecdotique il y a beaucoup d'aura
marseille j'ai pas sûr que ce soit liées
au papier qu'on laisse traîner
je crois que la ville de marseille est
gérée depuis 25 ans en dépit du bon sens
et nous avons un système qui fait que le
prélèvement des ordures c'est à dire
leur enlèvement est toujours régi par un
système qui est que le personnel ne fait
pas les heures alors en 2017 on a
supprimé le fini parti mais en réalité
il est toujours là c'est pas moi qui le
dit d'ailleurs ce sont les syndicalistes
je pense notamment à pierre godard de
laives déçus qui dit que le travail réel
et de moins de cinq heures pour pour les
les boules les éboueurs et puis pour le
reste je crois que nous payons pendant
25 ans recrutement clientéliste des
personnels de 2,2 du nettoiement qui
était plus recrutées pour leur capacité
à coller des affiches en réalité pour
nettoyer la ville donc ces éléments là
tous agglutinés nous conduisent à avoir
cette situation qui est déplorable
je veux souligner que l'hyper
centre-ville d'ailleurs comme s'était
dit dans votre reportage
il ya des efforts considérables qui ont
été faits c'est beaucoup plus propre
qu'avant mais il faut savoir que c'est
parce qu'aussi c'est une entreprise
privée qui a eu le marché et que c'est
donc entre le privé et le public un peu
comme les gendarmes et les policiers
vous tapez il y à 70% du personnel qui
est public sur le nettoiement delà de la
conseille de territoire de marseille et
30% qui privée mais il faut dire que
pour lui
personne proville il ya trois ans je me
dois de vous des amis je dirais le
paquet et que c'est vrai que l'hyper
centre-ville est beaucoup moins sales
que ce qu'il était dans le passé mais
comme le dit un certain nombre de
personnes qui ont été interrogées par
nadège tout à l'heure d'un mois de
reportage
c'est aussi parce que ce sont les lieux
touristiques et c'est ça qui met un peu
en colère avaient marseillais on le voit
dès qu'on sort de l'hyper centre bien on
retrouve une saleté repoussante de la
ville oui on l'a vu dans ce reportage
également dans les quartiers nord
effectivement hervé guillaume lacour des
contrées a pointé en tout cas des coûts
beaucoup trop élevés sur ces deals de
marseille et des habitants qui
apparemment sont fâchés avec le tri
sélectif
c'est un les coûts trop élevés parce
qu'il y à je cite la cour régionale des
comptes la quantité de déchets collectés
est anormalement élevé à marseille c'est
dû à quoi selon moi j'ai pas vous
répondre pour marseille ce n'est pas
spécifiquement le cas mais c'est vrai
que collecte des ordures ménagères et
propreté d'ailleurs qui sont deux
métiers différents et on les associe un
petit peu mais c'est vraiment deux
métiers différents et ça peut-être gérer
une façon très différente la plupart du
temps vous pouvez avoir une propreté
urbaine qui est gérée par le maire parce
que c'est très sensible et très
politique à qui incombe cette
responsabilité c'est au maire
aujourd'hui sommeil l'activité au maire
il peut y peu par délégation transférer
cette compétence là à la métropole par
exemple mais mais c'est mais qu'on avait
les salles on dit c'est monsieur le
maire n'a pas fait le boulot quand même
donc on est on est très souvent comme
allant dans les grandes métropoles la
tendance du transfert parce que des
économies d'échelle qui se font se fait
aussi mais néanmoins en règle générale
un cas comme toulouse par exemple il ya
une complexe est une compétence
métropolitaine mais là le la ville de
toulouse a ses propres équipes
c'est à dire que ça reste on reste en
lien avec l'habitant et c'est là qu'ils
font des amateurs y arrive et pas
marseille alors que nous à des
difficultés marseillais des difficultés
paris à des difficultés moi je connais
pas deux villes qui n'ont aucune
difficulté
l'enjeu ça bien été dit dans le
reportage c'est on est on est sûr
en fait la ville elle se salit lé pa
salle elle se salit donc il ya
effectivement par des comportements des
usagers
alors après il ya des niveaux
d'équipements qui sont pas les mêmes
partout paris annonce par exemple une
corbeille tous les 100 mètres
oui on m'en parlait on en est loin
d'être là partout mais il ya les
équipements et là la plupart du temps
l'équipement est là et même des fois
l'équipement je vais vous citer un
exemple ces arènes très intéressant
petit jardin de la confluence à rennes
superbe beau jardin bien refait et tout
donc quand il fait beau tout le monde à
pique-niqué là il y avait une quinzaine
de corbeil est qu un score bas il ne
suffisait pas il fallait mettre trente
quarante cinquante corbeil et finalement
la ville a décidé d'enlever ses 15
corbeil complètement et de mettre un
système de tri à l'extérieur de ce
jardin et ça marche beaucoup mieux c'est
à dire que la même si sur ce point là la
ville a choisi de déséquipés mais les
amener en plus de dire devant vous venez
pique-niqué ici vous repartez et vous
triez en plus dehors et ça fonctionne
c'est à dire qu'à un moment donné il ya
un discours responsabilisant de
l'intelligence qui peut marcher alors ça
peut pas se faire par tous parce que là
on a un site remarquable
on a confiance être un très joli site ça
veut pas se faire partout mais c'est un
peu ce qu'on essaye de faire elle avait
pu c'est d'inciter les villes la
propreté c'est deux choses
c'est certes du nettoiement mais c'est
aussi mais c'est la présence aux
salissures et finalement quand vous
regardez un budget d'une direction
propreté aujourd'hui c'est encore 95 à
99 % au nettoiement et 1 à 5% d'après
d'anciens salissures donc pas assez des
comportements des incivilités qui sont
récurrentes à cette question de la
propreté revient régulièrement dans les
élections et dans les préoccupations des
français frédéric lazorthes ces
incivilités ça date pas d'hier
non ça te dire disons que le problème
c'est que plus généralement ce qui
caractérise le sans doute la france
c'est qu'on a tendance à se remettre aux
pouvoirs publics pour des tas de choses
il relève aussi des comportements
individuels quand on parle d'incivilité
on parle dans le problème au sens large
qui est que de plus en plus de souvent
les individus ont du mal à prendre leurs
responsabilités dans l'espace public
quand il constate une incivilité
et je prends un exemple très simple il
ya quand même eu un grand progrès dans
les dernières années en matière de
propreté qui est les déjections canines
vous trouverez difficilement aujourd'hui
à ses dépens
paris dans un deuxième temps comme déjà
il ya comme des progrès oui les
propriétaires de chiens aujourd'hui en
de plus en plus de deux sortes plus en
plus équipés alors sa licence en droit
mais dans quel quartier mais ça c'est
rentré dans les moeurs je veux dire il
ya un travail de sensibilisation qui est
important je voudrais revenir sur un
point que vous avez dit quand même
depuis 99
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que la
gestion des déchets relève des des
communautés de communes donc partout ce
soit la propreté urbaine alors la
propreté urbaine s'il s'agit de mettre
de disposer des poubelles etc ou les
étoiles espace plus d'un an et d'une
partie du nettoiement mais pour toute la
gestion des déchets qui est quand même
le gros de la problématique de la
propreté notamment c'est le gros parce
que c'est là où ceux où se caractérise
les problème de différenciation de
traitement entre les quartiers
évidemment vous pouvez toujours avoir
une politique pour l'hyper centre mais
après comment vous quand vous êtes à la
tête d'une métropole vous gérez d'autres
quartiers plus périphériques il s'agira
donc la salomé au coeur de l'enjeu des
municipales souvent les citoyens ne
savent pas vraiment qui est responsable
de quoi
en la matière les vers qui se tourner je
lui dis à tout un système de délégation
de compétences etc
alors il est évident que le maire et
notamment dans des villes comme
marseille paris ou lyon où il ya des
maires d'arrondissement ce qui complique
encore est l'interlocuteur numéro un qui
peut faire à limite pression mais il n'a
pas tous les moyens entre les mains
c'est ça la difficulté est donc je pense
que là peut-être notre
notre interlocuteur à marseille pourrait
nous nuire mais le problème c'est qu'on
est rentré dans un un caractère un peu
politique on veut pas rentrer dans tout
le monde est co gestionnaires du système
à marseille depuis depuis longtemps et
c'est un et c'est un domaine assez
lucratif également on va en parler hein
donc avec des appels d'offres voilà il
ya aussi des preuves de corruption
patrick mennucci dans cette gestion vous
disiez qu'il y avait des améliorations
notamment à marseille dans les beaux
quartiers uniquement est ce que c'est
pour satisfaire un électorat selon vous
je crois que je crois surtout que le
maire de marseille en avais un peu assez
et à penser que en rendant plus propres
l'hyper centre-ville c'est à dire autour
du vieux port et de la mairie de la rue
de la république il réglerait le
problème en réalité bien sûr le problème
n'est pas réglé parce qu'elle est
marseillais ne sont pas idiots une dame
le dit dans le reportage les rues
adjacentes elles sont très sales mais ce
que je veux préciser c'est que la
responsabilité de la propreté
elle incombe à la métropole et les pros
et et de l'enlèvement des déchets mais
qu'il y a une possibilité de faire de
passer la responsabilité à la ville et
non pas le contraire dans la loi cette
proposition a été faite à maintes
reprises à marseille
les maires d'arrondissement que
et qui était cité il ya un instant n'ont
aucune responsabilité à marseille dans
ce domaine et je crois que le problème
vient en partie de là c'est à dire qu'il
n'ya pas d'élu en responsabilité la
responsabilité est terne au président de
la métropole
mais imaginez quand même qu'à marseille
la métropole c'est un million trois cent
cinquante mille habitants et que donc
c'est extrêmement loin c'est pourquoi
des propositions souvent été fait mais
jamais suivies d'effet pour que la
responsabilité de la propre et urbaine
je ne parle pas de la collecte qui est
un process industriel évidemment mais de
la pauvreté urbaine soit donnée aux élus
de proximité c'est à dire au maire
d'arrondissement ou merde secteur comme
on dit avancer on parlait des
responsabilités denis demonpion alors il
ya évidemment on l'a vu les gens qui
sont dans la rue qui n'ont pas forcément
des comportements très approprié il ya
également les commerces
il ya également
toutes ces personnes là qui met
finalement leurs poubelles pas forcément
bon endroit et qui ce qui fait que les
poubelles débordent c'est aussi ce parce
que jeter ses poubelles ça coûte cher
mais c'est le problème central
d'ailleurs parce que dit les français
déplorent que les villes soient salle
mais ils sont les premiers responsables
de ce problème parce que quelqu'un dans
le reportage le disais à marseille à
paris à nantes à rennes par tous les
gens jettent les mégots de cigarette ou
les paquets même si normalement il ya de
lui notre attention
les noms parce que pour une bonne raison
c'est que dans la plupart des villes
c'est incitatif mais il dresse très peu
de procès verbaux
d'ailleurs dans une ville comme nantes
ils font confiance au civisme des gens
disent voilà la menace c'est la peur du
gendarme est en réalité ils ne veulent
pas heurter les administrés donc les
déjections s'ils savent que voilà et les
déjections canines une ville comme paris
je crois que dernières statistiques
auxquelles on a eu accès avec mireille
et pas sur les jets de papier aussi etc
il ya eu 100 milles
contraventions dressées sait rien quand
on pense que il ya à peu près 30
millions de touristes qui viennent à
paris il ya deux millions de parisiens
sans compter tous les déplacements
quotidiens
donc c'est un chiffre totalement
ridicule maintenant on ne peut pas non
plus avoir des brigades parce que sinon
la fonction publique n'en finit plus
voyez des brigades
donc je ne sais pas ça manque néanmoins
se regardent ils sont 6 e moins de 10 en
général alors cessé la ville infinie des
finales
mais non il ya un comportement à
apprendre aux enfants dès le plus jeune
âge et ça c'est l'éducation civique
c'est les parents d'ailleurs les
éboueurs eux-mêmes que mireille et moi
avons interrogés ils le disent ils
quand on leur dit voilà vos
comportements ont-ils toujours été
irréprochable mais on doit avouer que
depuis sont des pollueurs qui sont aussi
voilà obligée de l'écologie mais ils
disent que maintenant ils sont vraiment
conscients du problème et quand ils ont
des enfants 1h10 ramasse ne laisse pas
traîner tes papiers un kleenex etc etc
enfin à paris le lendemain de la fête de
la musique les berges sont vraiment un
tas d'immondices mais considérable c'est
des tonnes et des tonnes de de saletés
que ça reste vraiment partie des
épisodes voilà donc le nom mais il y en
a beaucoup vous savez il ya une forme de
logique mais il ya la techno parade mais
est ce qu'une manifestation
frédéric un naze or qu'est-ce que les
incivilités augmente finalement ou est
ce qu'on constate une amélioration
moi je pense que alors ça c'est au cas
par cas je n'irai quand on est
l'instabilité toujours l'autre je pense
que c'est ça le problème
mais comme je le disais tout à l'heure
je crois que les citoyens doivent se
réapproprier leurs espaces publics et
commencé eux mêmes à se civiliser mais
aussi à dire à à côté quand on voit une
famille où les enfants jettent dire
écoutez vous devrez aider à votre enfant
vous s et c'est quelque chose d'assez
simple mais on a relancé nous mêmes
parce que les femmes ils la font chez
elle chez elle mais peut-être voyage
dans l'espace public enfin il faut
encore espérer l'imaginé ont peut-être
pas dans l'espace public c'est quelque
chose de plus générale c'est quand même
très frappant que la france se
caractérise aussi par le fait qu'ils
aient une démission de quand il quand
vous êtes témoin d'une agression il ya
une dans le métro moi personnellement ça
ne m'est jamais arrivé mais les gens
préfèrent se retirer plutôt que alors qu
en nombre ils sont plus nombreux donc
ils souhaitent aussi une question de
comportement général on cite aussi des
tas d'exemples on sait qu'on voit des
gens qui vaut des pickpockets
allègrement volet des touristes et
qu'ils n'interviennent pas ou qu'ils me
disent rien et c'est vrai que c'est tout
ce comportement là qui doit changer on
peut pas en attend attendre toujours des
pouvoirs publics afin de sanctionner les
pour lui doivent sanctionner mais les
citoyens même doivent se responsabiliser
et aussi se rapproprier eux-mêmes
l'espace public savoir dire à quelqu'un
écoute ta nature ramassent les déchets
là tu fais c'est tout à fait l'enjeu on
fait tout l'enjeu il l'est de travailler
sur l'appropriation des espaces publics
où le contrôle de l'espace public
en fait aujourd'hui une perception
souvent par l'usagé d'une certaine
permissivité
finalement je connais pas très bien la
règle je connais pas très bien le mode
d'emploi tiens mon voisin a sorti son
vieux canapé il l'a mis dehors
il a été enlevé or il n'est pas le
numéro il y avait rien qui indique donc
en fait si on en a à travailler ça et
après moi j'ai pas opposer sa répression
prévention il faut faire les deux
rivales on a différents leviers ou la
vue vous citiez la pronostiquent
déjections canines en 20 ans a vraiment
bougé et aujourd'hui vous voyez les gens
en sortir avec leurs chiens ils ont le
sac à la main pour montrer à tout le
monde qu'ils ont bien le sac à la main à
80 % à 80 90 % rens on a des en-cas
peut-être à leucan et distribuer
eux-mêmes les sacd partout en france
partons donc en fait il ya des
modifications de comportement mais il
faut qu'on travaille effectivement cette
appropriation de l'espace public ça
c'est fondamental
et ça commence à se développer juste un
exemple qui est intéressant c'est mais
ce qui a créé des ambassadeurs la
propreté et qui sont déjà habitants et
ses amis ça on va parler aux ils ont
cette capacité effectivement à un moment
donné à faire de la sensibilisation
autour d'eux a signalé m on va reparler
effectivement dans cette deuxième partie
de politique patrick mennucci je
voudrais qu'on soulève un point on
parlait de de clientélisme tout à
l'heure le un marché très juteux
finalement celui du traitement des
déchets il ya aussi des problèmes de
peau devant
à marseille on connaît les affaires il y
a eu une affaire célèbre qui n'a pas
encore été jugé qui s appelle la paire
guérini qui part d'une problématique
autour des décharges c'est vrai et ce
matin encore la presse locale de
marseille révèle des biens voilà vous le
mettez à l'antenne effectivement des des
illégalités autour d'une déchetterie ou
du personnel de la métropole dit au jura
si la justice le confirmer mais
prendrait des bakchichs pour permettre à
des entreprises de jeter sans payer et
d'ailleurs c'est un des problèmes qui
est soulevée à ses lecteurs passer avant
tout le monde en payant plus cher de les
faire face et avoir à payer un peu plus
cher mais je crois que ça a été dit par
monsieur de mon bien me semble-t-il tout
à leur céder l'idée que amorcèrent il y
avait plus de déchets que la cour des
comptes la chambre régionale des comptes
plutôt disait qu'il y avait plus de
déchets que ce qu'on trouvait comme taxe
bien c'est parce que tout simplement la
taxe spéciale qui est devrait être payée
par les commerçantes par les artisans
n'est pas prélevé
dans sa totalité comme de vrais l'avant
donc là on est avec on voit bien un
système administrative mais politiques
qui ne tiennent pas la route mais je
voudrais juste vous dire une chose parce
que monsieur monsieur la sorte a dit
tout à l'heure il fallait que les
individus que nous tous nous nous y
mettions et il me semble que la
meilleure façon de permettre aux
citoyens de s'y mettre au fond pour
employer une expression triviale
c'est le tri des déchets le prix des
déchets et la façon certainement la plus
civique au fond de traiter cette affaire
de déchets et c'est vrai que quand on
regarde les villes qui ont réussi dans
le prix ce sont les villes qui ont
plutôt de bons résultats je pense à nous
je pense à carbon de terrain pense à
rennes a strasbourg aussi et marseille
malheureusement est dans le peloton de
queue pour sabotage de prix et donc
quand on a un mauvais pourcentage depuis
général 26 qu'on a des problèmes de
propreté dans la vie ouais effectivement
on va continuer d'en parler merci
beaucoup patrick mennucci d'avoir
participé à ce débat sur la ville de
marseille
restez avec nous on continue bien sûr
sur les incivilités dans les villes et
les villages de france la propreté et la
gestion des déchets inquiète
particulièrement les parisiens et les
habitants en banlieue on va le voir
rester avec nous
[Musique]
ce qui s'est passé sur tesla si vous
voulez est assez symptomatique du reste
vous avez une déconnexion complète entre
la valeur et le prêt si vous prenez la
valorisation boursière c'est à dire on
est monté jusqu'à 165 milliards pour une
boîte qui depuis le début père en cumulé
6 milliards et demi je ne validerai pas
la valorisation actuelle qui est
complètement décorrélé des fondamentaux
en effet mais après il ira tout de même
les aspects dans cette société qui
peuvent être valorisés à une certaine un
certain montant au delà en tout cas de
voitures en elle même il y à la
technologie du logiciel qui est à
l'intérieur et il ya également les
batteries qui peuvent être vendus ou la
technologie qui peuvent être vendus à
d'autres personnes ils vont 350 mille
voitures
ça veut dire que vous valoriser la
voiture entre 400 et 500 mille dollars
la voiture c'est une manipulation cours
pur et dur
[Musique]
je
oui
[Musique]
il faudrait que les nations puissent se
regrouper notamment une troisième force
et c'est troisième force et l'europe
mais l'europe est incapable de faire ça
il y à une remise en cause de la
relation très privilégiée entre l'europe
et les étals et je pense qu'aujourd'hui
nous devrions développer un dialogue
france allemagne russie chez tout çà çà
çà çà çà çà paraît pas avancer dans le
bon sens quand même le risque pour nous
c'est de sortir de l'histoire
moi je suis convaincu que l'avenir des
relations internationales pour les 15
ans qu'il est c'est la relation entre
les etats-unis et la chine nous
européens si nous ne sommes pas capables
d'être le troisième pôle à ce moment là
on aura des fragilités et on sortira
d'histoire
[Musique]
pôle it mag la suite avec denis
demonpion journaliste et auteur de des
ordures et des hommes aux éditions un
bruche estelle un ouvrage co écrit avec
la journaliste mireille dumas hervé
guillaumont coordinateur de
l'association et des villes pour la
propreté urbaine et frédéric lazorthes
essayiste et chroniqueur au magazine le
point les français n'en peuvent plus des
décharges sauvages des poubelles qui
débordent dans les rues et des
encombrants qui ne sont pas ramassés sur
les trottoirs à cela s'ajoute à paris la
multiplication des rats aujourd'hui ils
sont deux fois plus nombreux que les
habitants de la capitale
estelle farges paris est elle devenue la
ville la plus sale d'europe
oui si l'on en croit cet article du
journal britannique the guardian
dans ce papier publié en septembre 2019
l'auteur qui s'appuie sur des
témoignages de riverains dépeint la
saleté et l'insalubrité de la capitale
allant jusqu'à surnommer parisot dirty
mind of europe
l'one salle de l'europe mais il n'ya pas
que le guardian qui se plaint de la
saleté des rues et des boulevards de la
ville
les parisiens en font une priorité pour
les élections municipales selon un
sondage ifop pour le jdd interrogé sur
ce qui va jouer un rôle déterminant dans
le choix du futur maire les parisiens
sont 69% à désigner la propreté c'est
même le premier facteur décisif devant
la lutte contre la pollution ou encore
la sécurité des biens et des personnes
alors comment lutter contre la saleté
parmi les initiatives mises en place
dans des villes de france
on peut citer les brigades de lutte
contre les incivilités entre sanction et
prévention et agissent contre les dépôts
sauvages d'ordures les jets de mégots ou
encore les tags et les graffitis et
pourquoi ne pas se servir de nos
smartphones le site sentinelles de la
nature point fr a lancé son implication
elle permet de signaler des dégradations
environnementales et d'agir en
collaboration avec les autorités ou des
associations compétentes
hervé guillaume il y a deux fois plus de
rats à paris que d'habitants comment ça
s'explique toujours avec ses déchets
alimentaire si on le savait on pourrait
on pourrait on pourrait travailler
dessus donc je pense qu'il ya plusieurs
facteurs alors bien sûr l'abandon le
fait qu'on déjeune de plus en plus
dehors on peut laisser effectivement des
miettes d des restes ça peut expliquer
je pense pas que ce soit le seul
la seule explication oui ou non un rapt
au logis en tout cas elles sont
catégoriques là dessus elles disent que
vous allez dans les squares partout vous
avez des sandwichs des restes des
reliefs de repas et ça suffit pour une
première une prolifération alors il faut
pas non plus jeter la pierre à tous les
rats puisque vous savez ils sont utiles
quand même dans les villes car à paris
il dévore 45000 tonnes de déchets quand
même vu leur nom c'est à cause de leur
jeu leur nombre ils sont près de 5
millions en effet et alors il ya une
spécificité de gros rats qu'isabelle le
surmulot qui fait à peu près 300 grammes
et on considère qu'ils dévorent de 5 à
10% de nourriture par rapport à son
point bas donc c'est c'est quand même
pas rien mais c'est vrai que c'est pas
agréable parce que c'est assez
repoussoir pour les gens qui veut pas
d'accord astique encore non mais vous
savez le problème
a paris il ya eu un nombre important
mais il ya eu l'installation de ces
poubelles en plastique en 86 à la suite
des attentats ou dring
et c'était d'ailleurs jean-louis debré
qui était ministre
voilà pour éviter
voilà ce qui s'était produit rue de
rennes et malheureusement ces sacs ne
résiste pas votre traitement au poids
tout ça donc ils se déchirent et c'est
une réjouissance pour les rares elles
frédéric lazorthes les déjections
canines à pari vous disais que ça
c'était un petit peu améliorée avec
guillaume on est vraiment en attendant
marié ghaoui trêve avant de bons posé la
question à écouter jacques chirac
c'était en 1982 il avait inventé la moto
crotte souvenez vous c'est une moto
équipée derrière sur sa roue arrière
d'un système spécial qui par brossage de
très rapide et sans eau de permet de
nettoyer les déjections canines
dès que le pilote voit une déjection
canine
il arrête sa moto de telle sorte que les
brosses spécial absorbe la déjection
dont les déchets reviennent dans des
sacs spéciaux et bio dégradable frédéric
lazorthes au secours les motos crois
qu'il faudrait qu'elle revient à paris
c'est sympa l'expert mais je pense
qu'effectivement c'est un bon signe
puisque si vous si vous dites que vous
avez un dispositif pour le faire à votre
place alors qu'est ce que c'était
efficace
je pense que c'est je pense que c'était
comme jacques chirac savait le faire une
bonne publicité pour montrer une action
concrète par rapport au félicia
l'occupation en 1982 oui messi mais
parce que en fait quand vous êtes quand
vous êtes
conseiller de paris où considérons
doucement vous êtes sur le terrain à
monsieur l'a fait quelque chose pour ça
donc c'était je dirais c'était de
l'affichage derrière il ya quelque chose
de beaucoup plus profond à traiter qui
effectivement le comportement individuel
ça coûte beaucoup moins cher que ce
genre de machine qui n'est peut-être pas
très efficace d'ailleurs au demeurant et
qui renvoie à cette culture française du
c'est aux pouvoirs publics de s'en
occuper
voilà ça c'est une c'est une question on
est dans une ère de on est dans une
double r de demande de démocratie
participative
donc je moi je m'étonne parce que on a
le cas de paris par exemple il ya des
conseils de quartier dans à paris je
sais pas très bien quoi ils servent
puisque toutes ces problématiques qui
sont des problématiques de territoire
des espaces publics comme enlisé avec
monsieur medoukh j'ai tout à l'heure ne
sont pas prises en compte les délires
que la responsabilisation n'est pas vrai
on ne va pas vraiment jusqu'au bout
a paris vous avez deux types de quartier
il ya très peu de temps vous il ya un
reportage dans la presse de cette rue
qu'on a surnommé dans le monde
dans l'ems particulier la rue là puisque
j'habitais dans les viiie donc je vois
voilà je vois très bien on sait je vois
très bien quelle rue sais mais ça fait
des années que ce problème est là donc
il est difficile de faire comprendre à
des à des habitants des riverains qu' on
ne peut rien faire en terme de
répression
déjà la vidéosurveillance est une des
solutions est justement pour ce type de
comportement est ce qu'on a fait des
progrès depuis la moto crotte hervé
guillaume sur la vidéosurveillance on a
fait des progrès ce que l'enjeu il est
effectivement de faire évoluer les
comportements
on va aller nettoyer néanmoins à ce que
soient les nettoyer mais on va faire
évoluer les comportements et ça ça bouge
on l'a vu sur les déjections canines
hérité des poubelles qui arriva à
détruire aussi les déchets oui le
compact et logiquement aujourd'hui la
vidéosurveillance pour les gros dépôt
sauvage n'est pas utilisable mais ça va
l'être dans le cadre de bâle delà de
l'âge avec pourquoi pas légalement ces
directions mais ça va l'être un bon
garçon travaille sur ce texte là il est
il encourt un an d'étude et voire même
on aura accès aux services pourri même
pour identifier l'immatriculation et ça
sera le propriétaire du véhicule qui
sera là mais le dépôt vous sortez vous
sortez votre canapé vous tout seul bas
on va pas vous voir vous de vous allez
mettre une capuche et on saura qui pis
est donc en fait ce qu'il faut arriver à
convaincre ces deux ce soit mon copain
mon collègue mon voisin qui me disent tu
peux pas faire ça tu peux pas faire ça
aujourd'hui regardés avec les mégots buy
com c'est intéressant aussi les mégots
moi je je je regarde ça parce que le
sujet il est il et les déjections
canines 10 à 20 ans aujourd'hui tout le
monde balance son mégot maintenant 80 %
des gens balancent sur deux ça commence
on commence à voir des gens qui
utilisent les pc la présence de 30 à 40
% des déchets ramassés c'est énorme mais
c'est le déchet le plus courant sur
l'espace public est le plus compliqué
ramasser parce qu'il est entre deux
pavés il faut il faut l'aspiré pouvait
pas le balayer il vient pas non non
c'est le déchet qui en plus est
excessivement polluants là encore
une responsabilité élargie du producteur
vous faire que les cigares étaient vont
payer demain à partir de jeunes vont
payer donc je pense qu'on va gagner
là-dedans encore on va progresser c'est
à dire que le petit temps que les deux
poches que certaines villes distribuer
lors d'événements et tout sera
certainement distribué par le buraliste
ce sera comme pour vous parler de deux
brunes poirson tout à l'heure à la
secrétaire d'état à la transition
écologique et solidaire parle aussi des
des dépôts sauvages et ce ne sont pas
forcément les particuliers qui sont
responsables et les déchets du bâtiment
mais c'est 70% des déchets qui sont
produits en france parce que sous pas
souvent mais trop souvent encore ils
terminent dans des décharges sauvages
qui exaspère nos concitoyens
et ça ce sont des pratiques il faut
changer nous allons mettre en place par
exemple une obligation de diagnostic
pour savoir ce qu'il ya dans un immeuble
voilà donc donné de morpion ce sombre et
de mon client présent ce sont des monts
des dépôts sauvages qui proviennent de
la construction ça veut dire que les
et les personnes qui travaillent dans le
bâtiment jette aussi des affaires d'état
qu'on voit pas bien obligation de
diagnostic enfin on verra quelle forme
cela prend mais non ce qui est certain
c'est que en effet tous et tous ces
déchets inertes comme on les appelle et
bien
souvent une entreprise qui facture au
client
l'enlèvement des gravats voilà se donne
pas le mal parce que pourquoi parce
qu'il lui faut payer à son tour pour les
mettre dans une décharge
voilà et souvent c'est au poignet alors
voilà donc s'il ya un problème et qui
doit être assez facile à résoudre
d'ailleurs ne s'est pas laissé prendre
c'est le coût de cette prise en charge
est ce que c'est une des solutions mais
c'est le coup oui mais comment vont-ils
s'y prendre pour comment dirais-je
responsabilité responsable où il ya des
décharges mais souvent vous savez vous
vous travaillez en centre ville par
exemple une entreprise telle case des
cloisons et ses centres villes et il lui
faut les déposer en dehors de paris
s'il ya des embouteillages s'il y a des
difficultés de circulation des
manifestations c'est un problème pour
les entrepreneurs est alors souvent en
effet il se donne pas le mal de faire ça
et on voit dans même dans les beaux
quartiers souvent près du square des tas
de gravats des c'est ce qu'on raconte
d'ailleurs dans le livre est que
mireille dumas c'est invraisemblable de
voir que la cdu si vite ce qu'il
faudrait à moi la loi sur l'économie
circulaire va traiter ça aussi puisqu'il
y aura un d'un système de certificats
qui devrait être remis en fait aux
clients c'est à dire que l'entreprise
devra prouver la bonne élimination de
ces déchets ou alors là leur traitement
en amont ce qui éviterait dedans je t'ai
davantage c'est un fossile à la
philosophie de la de la loi anti
gaspillage rsa au gouvernement
actuellement faire plus de travail en
amont plutôt que de traiter après que
moi c'est ça a sign on s'en souvient un
maire a été tué dans le var parce qu'il
avait surpris un quelqu'un qui était en
train d'essayer de jeter des gravats
justement ça coûte cher aussi pour les
particuliers on l'a dit
on peut en venir à ce type de drame ces
incivilités et frédéric lazorthes
peuvent mener à ça c'est les maires qui
sont débordées par cette question
surtout les maires des communes de
petite commune parce que c'est aussi ça
que ça révèle c'est à dire que on a une
démocratie locale qui est quand même en
crise c'est à dire qu'on voit bien plus
généralement qu'il y a deux poids deux
mesures entre des quartiers centraux
dans certaines villes alors que bon on a
parlé de marseille des quartiers qui
seront pas l'abandon des des zones
périphériques et des petites communes
donc des zones rurales qui sont beaucoup
plus susceptibles d'être aux endroits où
on met des déchets des décharges
illégales et donc c'était eux alors eux
ils font affaire la nation ils ont ils
ont ils ont une commande et âge ça ne te
sens des officiers publics donc ils font
la police sur sur leur territoire mais
ils n'ont pas les moyens et donc n'ayant
pas les moyens
si le petit maire se trouve engagé tout
seul il est face à une délinquance qui
comme une délinquance routière il n'a
pas les moyens de ça je pense que les
citoyens à ce moment là ont compris un
problème aujourd'hui je ne suis pas sûr
que les élections municipales nous est
amené à y trouver une donnée est une
solution qu'elle appuie qu'elle soutient
donne ton assez maires de petites
communes qui ont des responsabilités sur
les épaules qui sont lourdes qui sont
souvent des engagements totalement
gracieux puisque c'est souvent beaucoup
des retraités qui font ça qui se
dévouent pour leurs concitoyens et qui
ont de plus en plus de responsabilités
mais de moins en moins de moyens et en
plus il ya le problème des comme des
deux communes
ça leur échappe même déversés dans
d'autres donc là il ya vraiment on voit
qu'il ya ça fait partie de la
problématique de rêve se réapproprier
l'espace public sera pourrie elle soit
public c'est aussi de savoir pour les
citoyens qui décide quoi et à quel
niveau et pouvoir interpeller dans
l'organisation même de l'espace public
ce que monsieur minucci disais tout à
l'heure finalement la ville de marseille
pourrait être approprié une partie des
responsabilités bien pourquoi ne pas
donner des moyens de police des moyens
beaucoup plus grand à des à des mères
qui sont confrontés à c'est assez
problématique là et comme si dans des
territoires qui intéresse pas tout le
monde était évoqué sa après la mort
justement du verre du 6 mai alors plus
généralement je pense que ça a été
évoqué et il ya une autre chose qui la
fait comprendre c'est la crise d'un
gilet jaune pour dire les choses
franchement on s'est rendu compte qu'il
y avait au delà de la france des
périphéries urbaines une autre france
périphérique encore plus périphériques
et ça concerne pas simplement les
citoyens ça concerne aussi les élus qui
sont dépourvus de moyens parce que ces
moyens vont de plus en plus basculé sur
des villes plus importantes sur des
collectivités qui sont au dessus mais en
fait c'est eux qui ont entre les mains
les plus grande partie du territoire ou
bien se rendre compte de ça il ya une
frange de ses grandes que de ces
communes françaises il ya trente plus de
30 mille communes françaises on sait
qu'on veut les les petit à petit de
l'hymne et le petit nombre de communes
et ça n'empêche que ce sont des
territoires et ses territoires c'est là
où il ya des décharges illégales c'est
là où il ya le plus de problématiques de
de développement durable et c'est là où
effectivement c'est pris en compte plus
tardivement mieux redéfinir finalement
les responsabilités sur cette question
la responsabilité de solidarité la
démerde 2
ville
6 8000 habitants qui ont beaucoup
développé ces vingt ou vingt-cinq
dernières années les déchetteries il ya
des villes qui ont une égale sur
territoire français le fait d'avoir une
déchetterie où passe ça joue aussi en
tout cas il ya des régions moins que je
connais qui sont très fourni voilà et ça
fonctionne plutôt bien
il n'empêche que le problème central est
quand même un problème de comportement
car il ya toujours des gens qui
choisiront des sous-bois pour déposer
leurs ordures leurs encombrants etc etc
et ça c'est très difficile de les
localiser et mais il ya un autre
problème aussi dans c'est la quantité de
déchets qui est produite et ça c'est
considérable et il ya un des moyens de
lutter contre ça ce serait de faire en
sorte que par exemple tout ne soit pas
jeté un voile à jetables emballé dans
alors il ya une prise de conscience il
ya une vie d'abord une première loin
2016 la loi à garowe vous savez pour
contraindre les la grande distribution à
ne pas jeter comme ça donner aux
associations ça n'a pas complètement
mention les aliments
voilà ça n'a pas complètement réglé le
problème et puis en décembre dernier il
ya eu un ajout qui a été
fait à cette loi pour faire en sorte que
à l'échéance 2020 25 27 ou 30
en effet les comment dirais je les fasse
fuld les restaurants la recette ne ne
jette pas non plus ils ne produisent
plus autant de déchets les déchets et
faire du tri sélectif à leur niveau
voilà parce que de toutes les villes et
même les petites villes ont tous lors
comment diriger l'établissement de
restauration rapide est évidemment ça
entraîne la pollution et aucun doute qu
elle est brune poisson qui dit il faut
faire un diagnostic comment est ce
possible alors que forcément ce problème
des déchets sauvages c'est fluctuant en
s'émouvant oui c'est émouvant mais à la
fois il se répète très souvent dans les
mêmes endroits comme on le sait un sur
les bords des routes à grande
circulation de paris il ya eu d'accroc
l'a complètement jonché à déchets alors
ça c'est plutôt les riverains
quand on est en grandes villes qu'on est
dans un centre ville c'est le propre des
riverains avec avec un appel auront
peut-être un peu moins à paris parce que
ce système là n'est pas trop développées
mais on va le retrouver en province
c'est ce qu'on appelle les points
d'apport volontaire qu'on a mis où il ya
du tri d'organiser mais finalement le
geste de se dire ah bah ça va être
collectées à cet endroit là donc je
dépose mes cartons donc je dépose mon
vieux canapé donc je dépose totaux alors
c'est toi qui est vraiment une
photographie qu'on peut qu'on peut faire
c'est ce que vous disiez il ya des oui
oui on a on connaît les au palais mais
reconnaissent des endroits critiques où
il ya des dépôts récurrents dépôts
sauvages ou des charges des charges
quand on est en la ruralité oui tout à
fait alors face à ce problème il y a
évidemment les citoyens est de plus en
plus d'initiatives on le voit grâce aux
réseaux sociaux pour signaler des
comportements pas très pas très propre
on va le voir notamment en banlieue
parisienne ça s'appelle le clean
challenge l'objectif c'est de nettoyer
sa cité de fond en comble et mettre au
défi une autre cité d'en faire autant
justement via les réseaux sociaux et ça
marche regardez moi c'est ma conscience
qui va défier ouais c'est quand j'ai vu
l'affiché
pourquoi pas chez nous en fait voilà on
parle et dont on avait déjà pour projet
de lancer ce type d'opération ne savait
pas comment avec qui quand et là le gars
qui challenge c'était l'opportunité
idéale pour emboîter ont essayé de
rouler c'est une leçon de civisme en
fait pour les générations futures et
pour que voilà que ça soit plus normal
que dans une cité on
je t'ai serrano d'un faux pas pourquoi
que voilà jeté quelque chose par terre
c'est pas normal c'est par anodin c'est
pas habiter dans une cité et que c'est
sale c'est pas anodin
freda glaz art on voit un les
comportements de citoyens qui viennent
nettoyer sur les plages des cités ça se
multiplient parce que les gens vous
compris finalement qu'il fallait avoir
un comportement vertueux
les réseaux sociaux ont fait beaucoup
aussi pour progresser sur cette question
les réseaux sociaux mais aussi les
municipalités puis ensuite il ya vous
avez des cervelles même aussi oui il se
sert des réseaux sociaux qui par exemple
vous avez les cas comme la ville
d'angers
il ya eu il ya eu des initiatives qui
sont poussés pareil ça revient au même
de dire aux habitants
c'est votre espace public fait en sorte
que ce soit un bel espace public
on avait à une époque sur la question
d'insécurité la théorie de la vitre
brisée
c'est la même chose une ville sale
incite à se comporter de manière assez
peu précautionneuse en général une ville
de plus propre un espace plus propre
incite à se comporter de manière plus
vertueuse je pense que c'est ça aussi
qui est un mouvement plutôt intéressant
et encourageant parce que là ce sont les
citoyens eux mêmes qui sont à
l'initiative qui se lancent des défis et
surtout dans des dents dans des villes
périphériques de la région parisienne
avions fait pas qu'ils sont des ménages
n'ont pas forcément une bonne image et
puis en fait les pouvoirs publics s'y
intéressent beaucoup moins appuyé les
problématiques des élus devront se
retroussent leurs manches et lorsqu'ils
le font eux-mêmes c'est un bon c'est un
bon signe effectivement c'est un bon
signe qu'ils envoient aux autres à leur
arrivera à votre habitants alors
concitoyens est alors aux pouvoirs
publics également c'est à dire que les
maires seront incités à aller vers des
comportements plus vertueux et à les
pousser les habitants à aller vers ces
comportements est-ce que c'est pas non
plus excuser moi un denis demonpion mais
finalement que les que ce soit les
habitants qui le fasse c'est pas non
plus avec le faire ce serait plutôt
pouvoir
écoutez toutes les initiatives
individuelles est bon à prendre en la
matière oui ça y est le manque justement
de moyens peut-être de ces communes pour
bien sûr mais voyez par exemple pour le
gaspillage alimentaire il ya deux jeunes
gens qui ont lancé des en bretagne
d'ailleurs la plupart de leurs boutiques
et leur magasin centre bretagne sénou
anti gaspi c'est à dire que tous les
produits qui ne sont plus tout à fait
qu'ils sont pas gâtés encore mais sur le
point de l'être
ils les reprennent
ils vont à rungis ils vont chez les
producteurs directement et ils les
vendent le tiers de ce qu'ils
trouveraient dans la grande distribution
et ça fonctionne ça fonctionne très bien
parce que leur petite entreprise se
développe pas seulement bretagne ils ont
créé les emplois et il crée des emplois
et puis ça évite le gaspillage ça évite
en effet que des emballages se retrouve
au coin des rues etc
donc il faut saluer tout c'est tout
cyclables et ça se fait régler mairie en
fait hein parce que l'organisation d'un
grand nettoyage d'un cleanup la ville
est associée toujours aux céréales qui
va apporter même des outils qui va donc
c'est un communiqué parce que c'est vrai
que les communiqués vraiment aidé ce qui
est fantastique dans le reportage
convient de voir c'est que ça se passe
aussi dans les quartiers à la socio
jusqu'à présent 10 et finalement c'est
les gens qui se comportent bien qu'ils
participent au kindle c'est le bobo qui
y va et où qu'ils donnent bonne
conscience et tout mais c'est pas celui
qui salit qui a participé
et là je veux pas dire que dans les
cartes mais voilà ça se généralise ça va
ailleurs et il ya des jeunes il ya des
communautés qui se mobiliseraient
d'amour aussi avec la communauté sikhe
participer au clean up pensez vous
franchement intéressant parce que tout
d'un coup effectivement elle ça devient
quelque chose qu'on partage à plusieurs
avec avec tous mes voisins et tout est
de faire mieux qu'une autre site et
qu'israël est ça aussi ça marche bien
frédéric frédéric la zone j'aimerais
juste pour pour conclure moi essayer de
remettre ses perspectives dans les
problématiques plus larges sur les
questions environnementales parce qu'il
ya ce qui est visible skis non visibles
les questions de déchets
de propreté des villes soient aussi
revenu par les questions des dépôts lui
la pollution urbaine donc vont
concentrer l'attention des pouvoirs
publics
mais il faut aussi voir derrière qu'il
ya toute une en tout un aspect de la
ville qui la ville comme lieu économique
nous on en oublie qu'il ya quand même
des endroits des villes des lieux
d'habitation qui sont à côté de
d'activités économiques sensibles
on a vu la roue encore inquiète encore
une ville où il ya de l'activité
industrielle dans les zones d'habitation
et elles ont été petit à petit sortie
mais quand même il faut pas faire que la
ville devra juste une ville de services
il ya une ville aussi d'industrie a
inventé que d'une ville industries
propres de protection des habitants et
puis un autre plan qui paraît très
important notamment sur le tri sélectif
c'est que les citoyens ont le sentiment
quelquefois le leader ben finalement au
moins je trie mais derrière ça suit pas
et donc il ya tous est cette obligation
d'information je pense qu'il doit être
donnée aux collectivités de dire
exactement ce qui est fait du tri
sélectif comment on progresse et c'est
parce que sinon c'est une démobilisation
une démotivation aussi donc il ya deux
sujets la chaîne finalement soit
vertueuse sur la chaîne soit vertueuse
marche qu'elle rende des comptes
et derrière aussi qu'on n'oublie pas que
la ville c'est aussi un lieu d'activités
économiques et compense aussi aux zones
d'activités sensibles comme les usines
seveso axelera qu'elles sont exposées
les habitants c'est aussi un risque
c'est ce souci et des questions et
demain je pense que ça participe aussi
l'appropriation espace public il faut
plus d'information plus de que les
entreprises avaient plusieurs les
habitants qu'on montre plus ce qui est
fait par ce quelque chose qui sont
faites et qui a un aspect des normes
mais qui n'est pas l'idée que l'actif
d'économie doivent sortir des villes
d'activités industrielles loi pas
uniquement sortir du mythe c'est pas la
réponse
on va passer à nos questions réponses
est plutôt le résultat de notre sondage
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
les questions réponses on a posé la
question sur nos réseaux sociaux faut-il
davantage de répression contre les
incivilités
voilà la réponse 62% des sondés sur rt
france
évidemment ce qui ne représente pas
forcément la majorité des français
disent oui à 62 % ce qui paraît plutôt
étonnant 1 par rapport à ce qu'on a dit
autour de ce débat éric viol puisque ils
vont vous disiez vous une fois à peu
près il faut équilibrer finalement un
peu la répression est aussi le flair des
deux pour faire les deux il faut faire
les deux dany rien mais en tout cas les
résultats du sondage ne me surprend pas
du tout parce que quand on vous faut sur
l'autre c'est ça non mais comme des gens
voient quelqu'un jeter un papier ou
laisser son chien faire ses besoins et
ne pas ramasser ça grogne est donc c'est
vraiment pas surprenant
elle serait le fait qu'ils aient si peu
de contraventions dressées
ça explique la lenteur alors aussi
évidemment il ya un autre problème c'est
la production des déchets en étant
surconsommation pour tous car il ya une
autre forme et un autre type de déchets
qui sont les deux les déchets toxiques
dans les dépenses effectives mais voila
voila c'est un problème de
d'environnement on parle de transition
écologique et tout ça mais là il en est
vraiment du travail à faire
merci beaucoup mouillé dernier vous êtes
secondes alors non non c'était juste
pour relever sur sur les déjections
canines et la verbalisation
moi j'ai rencontré toutes les polices
municipales de france sur ce sujet là
ils m'ont dit on ne voit jamais flagrant
délit parce que les gens sont plus fou
c'est ça qui nous avaient pas le cas
avec son habit et ils profitèrent de
chiens ils ramassent devant lui et il
peut pas à verbaliser sur délation donc
c'est compliqué voilà en tout cas merci
à tous d'avoir répondu à nos questions
et d'avoir participé à ce débat c'est la
fin de police mag
restez avec nous l'info à suivre
[Musique]
je ne sais pas quoi dire les gens du
foot où elle travaille ici au milieu des
ordures
et j'ai dit à mes amis qui travaillent
ici qui peut être prudent un jour ça va
devenir à cimetière ici ont cassé des
charges